Dr. Zak, my name is Tara. I am a
merchant.
My question is there is difference
between
how when a Christian or a non-Muslim in
general
convert to Islam
and when they
an Islam convert to another religion.
What I want to ask is
why the Islam
would react so violently
>> they would
stay away from that person or something.
>> Are you asking if someone becomes a
mortad why the Muslim community is harsh
on them? Is that what you're asking?
Yes,
I get the disappointment but I don't
think we should go that far.
>> Brother as a question when a non-Muslim
become a Muslim we happy
>> but if a Muslim becomes a non-Muslim why
are we angry?
>> Yes
>> brother.
>> Yes.
>> If your son
does charity
does good deeds become a doctor saves
the human me will you be happy or sad?
happy.
>> If your son becomes a robber, a thief,
murderer,
will you be happy or sad?
>> I will be sad.
>> So that's the answer. Someone coming
from the wrong part to the straight path
is like a non-Muslim coming to Islam.
And someone who's a Muslim going to the
wrong path, you should be sad because
you're going from the straight path to a
wrong path. A Muslim is a person who
submits his will to God. A Muslim is a
person who follows the teachings of the
Quran. They say hadith. So if someone
who's a good person becomes a bad
person, we have to feel sad. So this is
logical. Hope that answers the question.
>> Yes.